are aliens Among Us a military
whistleblower going public with some
incredible claims about UFOs being
hidden from the public the former Intel
operative says there's a secret
government program that has been
retrieving crafts of quote non-human
origin for at least several decades as
well as the alien Pilots
these are retrieving non-human origin
technical Vehicles you know call it
spacecraft if you will it's probably not
the right parlance but uh no kidding
non-human exotic origin vehicles that
have either landed or crashed we have
spacecraft from another species we do
yeah
okay I'll start with you
I think is this whistle whistleborg
count to the safety of average Americans
I
feel that this story is a lot like
Harold Ford Jr too good to be true
pull UFO stuff and it bubbles up every
like two to three weeks it used to be a
couple of months yeah is how badly
everybody wants it to be true because we
have such a decline in religious belief
and and people are desperate for
something Beyond this troubled or been
our mortal coil and we're ready to
embrace what's called like the
woo-woo-ness of a story oh it's so
exciting it's exciting and we do that
with AI friends of mine especially love
this idea because the possibility of the
idea being the biggest idea ever if we
do have alien life there's nothing like
that since the since the beginning of
time so people want this to be real this
guy sounds reputable but he's relying on
other Witnesses he hasn't seen anything
so I don't buy it whatever exists exists
outside our time and space I believe and
maybe when we see things it could be
like little glitches like maybe a system
update you know that you get on your
computer where you see little weird
things that's all you all this could be
is just little system updates
but there's no aliens all right all
right
uh The Whistleblower claims that there's
an arms race for people
um who can discover collect those UFO
objects or the origins of them there is
and this guy's in the military right so
if you're at the Pentagon and if you
have spacecraft what do you do you hoard
it because you don't want China Russia
you don't even want France to have this
stuff so you reverse engineer the tech
and then you give the patents to these
defense contractors and they get rich
and then you could get some crazy
spacecraft that we can fly circles
around the Russians with and then you
call everybody who's hot on the trail a
conspiracy theorist and that stigmatizes
them so they don't get too close because
judge what's the role of the government
one of the main roles is to make sure
the population doesn't panic if you come
out and you say you know what we've been
lying to the country for the last five
decades we've been collecting
spacecrafts and aliens for a while
what's gonna happen people are never
going to trust the government ever again
there's going to be run on banks there's
going to be weapons stockpiling all hell
could break loose there's going to be
mass panic people took pills because
during covid imagine if you tell them
there's little green men that the
government's been hiding from us
everyone's going to go nuts they lied
about JFK exactly they lie about
everything you know Dana despite all of
these alleged breakthroughs I mean
nobody's answered the question have we
had Direct contact with any of these
UFOs well it's a secret secret uh office
apparently at the Pentagon maybe
elsewhere and I I would say that the
Pentagon Chief did say that there has
been some sort of unidentified metallic
orb spotted all over the world so it's
not just an American phenomenon there's
there are people around the world who
believe that they have seen things I am
just going to wait until I need to worry
about this like right now I think we
have plenty on our plate I don't think I
can add this any judge I'll meltdown
before you go to Herald I would like to
volunteer to take three aliens into my
house okay and you'll make you'll make
millions depending on what they tell you
all right if the U.S is far ahead of the
rest of the world in terms of these UFO
sightings
um you know are we you know it's 300
times apparently higher than the global
median we've got 2500 sightings for 10
million people million we are really
we're really young okay so are we just
obsessed with them or is this thing real
I have no idea but I think we could
settle this if if indeed this
whistleblower uh indeed the government
refutes once it refute what he said to
come before the Congress and give us the
answer come before closed hearing and
with the intelligence Community give us
the answer I'm like Dan I'm skeptical
about this I mean I love the movie E.T I
do too but I just I don't I don't
believe that ETS you don't coming down
here phone at home anytime you didn't
believe that it was a great movie
it was a beautiful movie it was it was
wonderful story it's based on a true
story yeah did you have contact with ET
called many times okay up next apple
will let you curse like a sailor after
fixing its annoying autocorrect feature
I wanna Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interview views coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now